[Music]
back when researchers first analyzed the
genome of a brand new coronavirus in
wuhan
its genetic sequence looked like this
three weeks later researchers sequenced
the genome of the same virus
in a patient in seattle it had changed
here
and here and here these changes are
happening
all over the world the coronavirus is
mutating
it's changed hundreds of times since
january but researchers are concerned
about one mutation
in particular so my question is
is the coronavirus becoming more
dangerous
i'm cleo abram and this is answered by
vox
well there's two ways one can think
about danger
uh first is that the virus is uh causes
a more severe disease
and that doesn't appear to be the case
that's professor of immunology michael
farzan
he says the second way that mutations
could make the virus more dangerous
is if it becomes more contagious but
before we get there
here's the good news my understanding is
that most
mutations in the coronavirus but also in
every virus
don't actually change how it behaves in
our bodies
at all is that right yes most mutations
do not change very much
they actually are just part of the
process uh
of sort of selection and they go away
a virus at its most basic is just a
bunch of genetic
material packed into a protein shell in
the case of the coronavirus that genetic
material is
rna which is made up of four nucleotide
bases
you might remember the bases actg from
dna
with rna it's just you not t when the
virus gets into your body
its goal is to copy itself which means
it needs to produce
more rna and more proteins a virus
doesn't always make an exact
copy of its rna and when it makes a
random mistake in that copying process
that's a mutation but it's when it's
copying the proteins that things really
get interesting
within that newly copied rna each group
of three nucleotides
called a codon can instruct your cells
to produce one building block of protein
called an amino acid amino acids all
come with letter names too
d-g-y-i you get the idea different amino
acid combinations
mean different proteins but as it turns
out
several different codons encode for the
same amino acid
so for example say the nucleotides acu
mutated into a c g it's still going to
tell your cell to produce the exact same
amino acid
t this mutation doesn't change the
protein at
all we call those silent mutations but
even if it's a non-silent mutation
something that does actually change the
amino acid and
changes the protein that doesn't always
necessarily change how a virus behaves
in our bodies right that's absolutely
right in fact
the genetic code is designed to be
conservative meaning that
changes that it's likely to make are
likely to have
a minor effect on the function of the
proteins they encode for
so in general mutations are expected
in the course of an epidemic or pandemic
most of these mutations do not have a
strong impact
on the severity of the virus or even the
transmission of the virus
of course that's not always the case and
for covid19
scientists are concerned about one
mutation in particular that might have
an impact on how the virus
spreads the formal name is d614g
and that is a code for the individual
amino acids
at position 614 of this spike protein
that have changed i see okay so it's the
614th
amino acid and it changes from d
to g correct unfortunately d614g
just so happens to be in the part of the
genetic sequence that encodes for the
viral spike proteins
those key proteins that the chronovirus
uses to invade cells
the red protein that everybody sees on
the surface of the pictures of the
coronavirus
there's more of those on viruses with
this change
than on viruses without this change dr
farzan and his team
found that with more spike proteins the
mutated virus is more likely to infect
cells in culture in their lab
but infecting cells in culture is really
very different from it being more
infectious
out in the world between people right it
is certainly more likely to
infect a cell in culture
what the next step is to demonstrate
that our results in cell culture
translate to human to human transmission
okay so just to be super clear we don't
know that this mutation causes the virus
to pass more easily between humans
it does seem to be more transmissible
between cells in a lab
and it also seems to become the dominant
form of the virus as it spreads
where is this mutated version of the
coronavirus now
i actually everywhere the first
detection of this virus might have been
in germany in
late january and then you would see that
virus sort of grow up
in europe and you would see sort of a
mixture of viruses in the united states
but then
over time you would see more and more
virus
with this mutation so what we know right
now is that researchers believe the
mutations that we're seeing
aren't making cases of the coronavirus
more severe
they are concerned that the d614g
mutation
might make the virus more contagious but
the research so far is limited to cells
in a lab
and scientists just aren't sure yet how
the mutation will affect contagion rates
in the real world
and if you just remember one thing it's
this
does what we know about this mutation
change anything that people should be
doing in their daily lives to prevent
themselves and their loved ones from
getting or transmitting
coronavirus no just a reminder that uh
this is a very transmissible virus it
always has been it might have gotten a
little bit more transmissible
and you should be very careful
at every point to make sure that people
are protected
thanks for watching that was an episode
of vox's first ever daily show
it's called answered it's on a new
streaming app called quibby
and every day we take on a question
about what's happening in the world
right now
from the history of curfews to cicada
season
so if you want to check out more all you
need to do is go to the link in the
description
or download the quibby app on your phone
and search for vox or
answered i'll be there every day
[Music]